wir wollen uns diese aktuellen zahlen
mal genauer ansehen das lka gibt jeden
morgen die neuansteckungen bekannt also
es wird ernst so kurz vor weihnachten
die neuinfektionen haben einen neuen
höchststand erreicht 23 1679 neue corona
infektionen binnen 24 stunden
das meldet das lka heute morgen der
bisherige rekordwert war am 20 november
mit 23.600 48 erreicht worden
das rkw verzeichnete außerdem 440 neue
todesfälle binnen eines tages gestern
war ja mit 590 toten ein neuer
höchststand gemeldet werden geworden
schauen wir uns einmal die hotspots an
also die regionen in deutschland in
denen es besonders dunkel aussieht die
regionen deutschlands die besonders von
corona betroffen sind diese karte können
sie im übrigen jeder zeit auf bild de
abrufen dort können sie sich dann genau
ansehen wie es bei ihnen vor der
haustüre aussieht wenn wir uns die
regionen und landkreise mit den meisten
gemeldeten fällen innerhalb von sieben
tagen hier ansehen dann merken wir auf
platz eins liegt immer noch regen in
bayern gefolgt von bautzen aber auch
hildburghausen weiterhin auf platz vier
und hier sehen wir jetzt die
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner hat
das gerade angesprochen die instanz von
200 dieser wert ab dem weil sie
eigenständig bis zu den landkreisen
runter bis in den regionen runter
entschieden werden kann maßnahmen zu
ergreifen so wie es jetzt münchen
gemacht hat wir sehen hier rot
eingefärbt die regionen in denen die
institute über 200 liegt da sehr weite
teile von sachsen da sehen wir auch
münchen grau sind die regionen die noch
unter 200 liegen ja eine ganz wichtige
zahl in dieser krise ist die auslastung
der intensivbetten denn wir alle wollen
vermeiden dass unsere krankenhäuser an
ihre grenzen kommen
deswegen wollen wir uns jetzt auch diese
zeilen noch einmal genauer ansehen
wir sehen derzeit sind 27 1323 betten
belegt insgesamt auf den
intensivstationen in deutschland durch
corona patienten belegt sind 4300 zwei
betten derzeit in allen
intensivstationen in den krank
häuser in deutschland sind 4817 betten
noch frei mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dir hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren